der schon immer gerne nach Indien wollte
aber nicht das nötige Kleingeld hat oder
auch nicht über den Kontinent fliegen
möchte der kann nach London ins Haus
Hall wird auch als Little India
bezeichnet hier wurde sogar der berühmte
Film kick it like Beckham aufgezeichnet
und man hat wirklich das Gefühl in
Indien zu sein es gibt nicht nur Saris
und tolle Gewänder aber auch typisch
indische Speisen hier gibt's noch eine
absolute Empfehlung für euch wir waren
bei wattern Essen das ist ein Restaurant
das ist ein bisschen indisch aber auch
afghanisch angehaucht es gab Karoli Reis
selbstgemachtes Brot Safranreis Butter
chicken und eigentlich alles was das
Herz begehrt